so in south carolina it it is officially
legal and
available to
prisoners on death row to have a firing
squad it always made more sense to do
this
cheaper wait what not as barbaric as
like injected just blow your heart out
everybody shoots in the same space the
same place right the heart
and you just did you know that only one
person uh only one person is has like an
actual bullet no no that's not true one
person everybody has bullets except for
one person so nobody knows you don't
know for sure if you were the one who
killed them oh okay i gotta reverse yeah
because i know i know they did it so
when you have somebody miss and it would
be bad because yeah
[Laughter]
so everybody has a bullet except for one
person so in your heart you don't know
you're not sure if you're you were the
one who okay
uh so this is back in june south
carolina halted the plan executions of
two men brad and freddie owens because
the inmates only had the electric chair
option that'd be my last [ __ ]
electric chair the state decided to
postpone their execution until they
changed the broad river correctional
institution in colombia saying the
facility did not include the capacity to
perform firing squad executions
yeah i'd be so scared uh the fire the
uh will fire their weapons through from
the other side of the corner officials
the renovations cost the state 53 000
yeah apparently there was an issue with
the lethal injection they weren't able
to get the uh
the
injected material strong enough for
the people so they're like we can't
would you pick b you got electric chair
firing squad or lead injection firing
squad
shoot me take me the [ __ ] out yeah and
this article also says that they are the
person who's on death row is wearing
like a bag over their head so they can't
see when the shot's coming
or the room how scary
in japan i feel like lethal injections
you know they like shave your head and
you're like in that suit and you're like
facing the wall the double-sided mirror
i love that you're still thinking about
aesthetics right now dude it's nuts well
yeah yeah shave your head like you're
seeing ted bundy when he went in
the worst in japan
uh in [ __ ] japan you have um
what is it uh they don't tell you when
they're coming so you are on death row
and it just it's going to come when it
comes and you will never know it's
exactly like you're going to die you
know dude how about this lethal
injection causes severe pain which yeah
dude you're on death row for a reason so
[ __ ] you severe respiratory distress
associated with sensations of drowning
association yeah
yeah it's death yes the overwhelming
majority of cases dude i guess just
shoot me
well how about this having a cage
shoot me but don't i don't don't shoot
him with like a weird rifle give me to
do a bazook or something man you know
what i'm saying something like that
[ __ ] you uh
yeah oh no you should do create a
minefield and let me just walk through
the bottom no no no no no no be like
squid game that sucks because it blows
your balls off and yeah but he's but
he's dead yeah i'll be dead he'll be
dead my thing is making like squid games
we're like okay if you make across the
minefield there's a thousand mines
they're everywhere if you make crush you
got your freedom at least give me the
hope be like oh this okay
and then i blow up and die but i die
pretty stoked yeah you're trying
give me a chance yeah
you're probably good that's a big way
but if you do shoot me dude do it with a
goddamn rocket
uh don't do some [ __ ] gun like i need
yeah i got 22. like
yeah
massive crocodile jump in the water oh
try to swim across the river that'd be a
miserable day but which one do you want
snakes
crocodile only which one i want for sure
well the snakes aren't going to kill you
for sure snake's going to kill you for
sure but you there's only it takes
forever yes you go crocodile yo ow you
guys there you go all right well guess
we'll see in like a week or so you die
you die you die horribly and for three
hours four hours you just support
getting poisonous
go ahead and take the croc it's gonna
suck but he's gonna roll you you're
gonna drown right now i'll take the
snake to drown out crocodile
crocs it'll bite you pull you in the
water it's fine you drown you know
terribly no no you drown now
yeah you're terrible
blow me up with a rocket dude
what a wild conversation
gotten done is fast gun is quick
watch just just watch this yeah
i'm no all due respect to anybody who's
gone through this but um oh yeah because
you're listening just say bang watch
that watch out watch how it happens
oh i don't think so yeah that's it
valkyrie you ever seen valkyrie where
they get shot at the end bang yeah with
with with high caliber rifles do it
again bang
i don't think so yeah i don't know if
they get them right in the heart do it
one more time i'll make it more
realistic because
listen people that are probably shooting
are good shooters
or they're correctional officers
you really don't shoot them
okay
can you shoot me my [ __ ] eye okay
first of all ask me if i want a
blindfold you want a blindfold no
now but you know you have no choice
right now hold on you have a bag over
your head go ahead try to put it on me
that [ __ ] thing off me well then i
just shoot you like this
no watch no now say it back again
love my children
do you think you have time for that yeah
yeah you think outside
oh no okay watch right before ready just
say it ready aim ready ready hey my
children
i have two children enjoy that [ __ ]
yeah i get you guilty as [ __ ] also
speaking of the people who are going to
shoot you uh the article says they're
actually going to be volunteers from the
correctionals department the corrections
are the best shooters
i need navy seals
you need to [ __ ] snipe
hey dude here's the thing we're gonna
put you in this field we have our two
the best marksmen in the world with
sniper rifles yeah if you make it a
hundred yards you're free daddy and i'm
like oh i have hope i'm a zigzag or do
my thing that's right that's what you do
i want my heart filled with hope when i
get here you want your heart filled with
hope aorta now when they hit you in the
hip
and it hurts like a [ __ ] no if
you're doing zigzags they're gonna
they're gonna hit you and [ __ ]
yourself no no not though
i need you to run straight
i need a i need a straight line they're
going to catch you right back